so I have what I think is a very
important message for Hogwarts Legacy
fans and this journey that we've been on
together and guys I'm just going to be
totally upfront and honest with you it
is not some big breaking news piece I
know a lot of people watch the channel
for all the news and I get that because
we definitely try and post a lot of that
but we haven't really had much news
lately on the game but all that being
said I do think this is a very important
message and something that fans who have
been following this game for a long time
really need to hear and it's something I
needed to hear too because I just found
myself tonight you know looking back on
this week I was watching expecto goes
live stream earlier and I had my live
stream last night and just thinking
about how far we've come you guys from
that first week of the gameplay all the
way back in 2018 I think it was and then
of course when we finally got the
official reveal in 2020 when that
happened this channel was was nowhere
near what it was today the time of
lockdown the time of 2020 was an
interesting year for all of us but it
was a really interesting year for me
because it's when I committed to YouTube
and said hey I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
make this channel I'm gonna try and
enrich people's lives spread some
positivity cover something that people
want to know about and growing up a
Harry Potter fan and then having this
game be announced it just felt like the
perfect match and I want to be totally
clear with you guys this game without
even releasing has changed my life that
is not hyperbole at all it is completely
changed my life without even launching
and it's all thanks to you guys is
thanks to the people who watch these
videos to the people in the live streams
to the members to the commenters to the
likes every single one of you it's all
because of you and so my main message
today in this video this very different
type of video might I add but the main
message here the main takeaway is that I
want you guys to sure you enjoy the
journey enjoy this time that we have the
Calm before the storm because I was
reflecting back today just honestly like
I said getting nostalgic thinking about
how far we've come thinking about the
Journey of Hogwarts Legacy to where
we're at now and here we are all the way
I mean early November almost to the to
Middle November it's going to be
Thanksgiving here in the US before you
know it and then the Christmas holidays
will be here and then New Year's and
then it's February guys and that's the
release date for Hogwarts Legacy we
could get you know early copies may go
out in January and while it's going to
be an awesome time and I know we've been
looking forward to this for so long now
just remember that once the game is out
and we're gonna love it and we're gonna
play it and we're gonna have an awesome
time or there's going to be a lot of
great videos made about it we'll never
be back here in this moment where we're
at right now and I say this to you all
as a long time fan of the Harry Potter
series some of my best times in Harry
Potter my Fondest Memories were the
anticipation it was the journey it was
the anticipation the books were great
finally getting to read what happens who
lives who dies Who falls in love and how
the story finally ends yes that was a
title of a muggle net book all that was
great and I and I loved the story but so
much about the journey was about the
before times it was about the in-between
it was about the conversations it was
about the podcast it was about the
fanfics it was about all these other
things that happened around it and
that's not to say that this stuff won't
keep happening after Hogwarts Legacy
comes out I'm certainly gonna keep
covering the game as long as you guys
are interested hopefully we'll get
sequels hopefully we'll get I don't know
multiplayer components maybe they'll
decide to do a multiplayer game at some
point down the road but it will never be
the same and so here in the us as we
enter this season of Thanksgiving I just
am so thankful for you guys I'm thankful
for the dev team at Avalanche for making
this game a reality and I am thankful
for this time of anticipation because
like I said guys it's gonna get crazy
it's going to get so crazy there's gonna
be so much information flying at us we
know Chandler wood has said on Twitter
that before the end of the year gameplay
is coming we're gonna get Gameplay at
some point we're gonna get you would
think anyway another ASMR video or two
and then before you know it the game's
gonna be here there's gonna be reviews
popping up there's going to be early
preview footage there's gonna be who
knows maybe we'll even get an early copy
here that we can share at some point
whenever WB decides and then once the
game is finally here that's when things
really change right there will be people
who watch my channel now some of you
maybe even watching this video right now
who won't watch anymore and that's
that's fine I mean that's life that
happens a lot of you found the channel
because of Hogwarts Legacy I hope a lot
of you will stick around for whatever we
end up doing next but again I say that
not to make anyone feel bad just to make
you all thankful for this time that we
do have together here now waiting and
getting hyped getting excited for this
particular game because again going back
to the Harry Potter fandom thinking
about all of those years it was so much
about it was the relationships the new
people that I met because of this and
there have been so many great amazing
content creators pop up around this game
I was just chatting with James earlier
tonight James of expect to go if you
haven't checked out his channel and
you're a Hogwarts Legacy fan what are
you thinking get over there check it out
but just think about even talking with
James James and I probably wouldn't have
met if not for Hogwarts Legacy so many
of you would have never found this
channel if not for Hogwarts Legacy so I
just want to be clear to everyone
listening to this right now if I can get
a little sappy with you all for a bit
it's that I am so thankful I am super
thankful for every single one of you and
I hope you all have a fantastic holiday
season a season of Thanksgiving if you
celebrate the holiday and even if you
don't it's always great to reflect back
and be thankful and one of the things
that that I am so thankful for is the
Harry Potter fandom and so much of that
so much of my passion for this game is a
result of that it's a result of those
relationships and growing up and being a
fan of that series and just longing and
dreaming for this game and I just had to
put all of those thoughts in a video of
their own I'll link it here on the right
side of your screen now so definitely
check that one out next as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon